segundo bloque económico de nuestra
mañana en directo América Daniela Cómo
se ha sentido hoy miércoles Tengo mucho
sueño Raúl tengo que decirlo Bueno vamos
a despertar Porque todavía tenemos una
crónica que hacer el euro volvió a
cotizarse por encima del dólar solo los
días para el fin de semana Así es verdad
Bueno
pues la moneda que comparten 19 países
superó la paridad por primera vez en un
mes esto ocurre por las expectativas de
que el Banco Central europeo subirá el
jueves sus tipos de interés de forma
agresiva lo que ha desencadenado la
venta masiva de dólares los mercados lo
están apostando efectivamente a que el
Banco Central europeo suba sus tipos de
interés en 75 puntos básicos esto para
frenar una inflación de casi el 10% en
el bloque esto sumado a que también se
espera que la reserva Federal modere sus
salsas le ha dado un impulso al Euro
Daniela y el gobierno de Reino Unido se
va a tomar más tiempo para presentar por
supuesto Por qué pues Raúl la
declaración oficial sobre asuntos
económicos este presupuesto de ricisunak
estaba prevista para el 31 de octubre
sin embargo el jefe de la cartera
económica de Jeremy Hunt lo retrasó
hasta el 17 de noviembre el ministro
dijo que ya consultó este aplazamiento
con el banco de Inglaterra hay que
recordar que el Banco Central ya había
criticado que listrosa no le presentara
su plan antes para analizar cómo lo iba
a tomar el mercado y después inclusive
tuvo que salir a intervenir después de
la debacle que generó la propuesta del
gobierno estas fueron entonces las
razones para aplazar el informe
creo que he mostrado en el poco tiempo
que he estado en el cargo que estoy
dispuesto a tomar decisiones muy rápido
y estoy dispuesto a tomar decisiones
políticamente vergonzosas si son lo
correcto para el país si son de interés
nacional
ahora tenemos un nuevo Primer Ministro y
la perspectiva de una estabilidad a
mucho más largo plazo para la economía y
el país y en ese contexto una breve
demora de dos semanas y media es la
mejor manera de asegurarnos de que
tomamos las mejores decisiones Raúl hoy
también se refirió al tema la jefa del
fondo monetario internacional cristalina
yo lleva quien aseguró que espera que el
nuevo gobierno lleve a Gran Bretaña
hacia la sostenibilidad fiscal y agregó
que tenía razón al advertir al público
sobre estas decisiones difíciles que se
avecinan y Dani la economía es el pilar
del gobierno de Richi es una vaca no
pero bueno Mejor vamos a hablar de otra
cosa porque esta semana Será de
resultados empresariales Cuáles son los
más recientes
bueno el más reciente es la de la
compañía de tarjetas de crédito visa que
reportó ganancias por 15 mil millones de
dólares en su año fiscal 2022 que
terminó en septiembre Hay unas empresas
que terminan años Fiscales antes el 21%
fue el alza de estas ganancias frente al
ejercicio anterior en la víspera ya se
habían conocido resultados por un lado
de Microsoft que sobrepasó las
expectativas de Wall Street con ingresos
de más de 50 mil millones de dólares en
el tercer trimestre la ayudaron el
cambio hacia el trabajo híbrido que
impulsó la demanda de sus servicios
basados en la nube y que ayudó a
amortiguar la caída en el negocio de las
computadoras personales pero aunque el
negocio crece se está desacelerando la
matriz de Google alphabet Aunque subió
un poco sus ingresos no cumplió con las
expectativas ya que los anunciantes
redujeron sus gastos ante la
desaceleración económica Esto hace
pensar que otras empresas que dependen
de la publicidad van a tener
resultados Como por ejemplo meta la
matriz de Facebook que va a dar a
conocerlos Hoy después del cierre de
mercados Dani vamos con esos indicadores
entonces bueno no le traigo las
ganancias de Facebook pero sí le cuento
que
metaplatforms que es su casa matriz
pierde 4% en la bolsa en la apertura de
Wall Street Microsoft pierde también un
7% alrededor y alfabeto lo hacen casi un
9%. estos resultados de las grandes
tecnológicas están afectando
principalmente el índice nasda que es
que se estima que están así porque la
economía no está por buen camino en
Europa las bolsas operan mixtas muy
pendientes de los resultados
trimestrales empresariales también y de
la próxima reunión del Banco Central
europeo este jueves y las bolsas del
Asia Pacífico siguieron las subidas de
martes en Wall Street en medio de las
esperanzas de que la reserva Federal
pueda suavizar está alza de tasas de
interés Shanghai Tokio Hong Kong y
Sydney ganaron en la jornada Dani como
siempre Muchísimas gracias toda la
información económica mañana más
economía por supuesto con menos sueño
con menos sueño Claro que sí nos vamos
nosotros directo hasta París